we got Mike Tyson in the house guys
are you ready Mike Tyson is here we are
going to bring Mike Tyson in
uh
uh got a good one need some help all
right here we go all right Mikey what's
up buddy yo this is crazy man I've been
watching you forever and I'm actually uh
I read the book a couple of times too
man
um so I'll make I'm trying to make this
short um
I'm a travel nurse man I've been uh I
met my girl on a assignment we we've
been dating three years and
at the end towards the end of it bro she
just um she kind of just [ __ ] she's
like hey I'm not feeling uh I'm not
feeling this anymore I think we need
some time apart some [ __ ] like that and
so I just said I said [ __ ] it you take
your time apart I've heard you say say
this before Richard I said [ __ ] it you
know I'm out of here I took my [ __ ] and
I got out
within a week I was uh I said you know
what I tried to take her on a date but
she was like I don't want to get your
hopes up I was like then [ __ ] it I won't
that's the next day she took she went on
a date with some guy
and I realized they were [ __ ] and
it's been
I don't know I just I'm just I'm just
[ __ ] going through it and uh
yeah I realized they were [ __ ] who's
the guy was just the guy that she was
working with or I don't know I don't
know I have no clue I have no clue where
she found a guy but I don't know if you
uh have seen this meme but I got to put
it up on the screen because it's sort of
relevant to uh what we're talking about
here
this is the I just need some space meme
dude's got his face in his hands and
she's looking the other way saying I
just need some time and then we've got
the space over here
it's a bit man and that's just you know
it's just the reality of what it is man
you know it sucks to see it you know
especially when you're a position like
Mike's at but
um you know accepting it for what it is
so the next time you hear it I mean like
if you ever deal with that [ __ ] she's
like I just need some space you know we
need some time apart
and I'll say my question is that how do
I how do I get over this hurt quickly
man because I'm like two weeks into it
and I'm just I've been trying to work
out you know my buddy told me uh 28. how
many times you've gone through this
before
this is my third goal this is my third
goal man yes I need some space like she
lied to you and then you're safe yeah it
collapses there's even a worse one
before but yeah okay so so this is why
you know when I say [ __ ] like she ain't
yours you know it's just your turn yeah
nothing's permanent and then there's you
know those religious guys that get
pissed off Ah that's not true that's
like yeah okay well then welcome to Mike
you know like we're talking to Mike here
and this is his third time around I've
been through it a bunch of times too
right like there's a lot of guys out
there right now going you know been
there done it got the T-shirt you know
women aren't sugar and spice and all
things nice and there's some women
that'll lie to you in fact most women do
lie uh which is why you have to judge
them by their behavior so here's the
thing
see where can I start with you on this
yeah I know
um lean into the pain it's okay you're
gonna get through it doesn't matter it's
like pain is there to teach you
something okay that's what pain is it's
there to teach you something it's like I
[ __ ] up and I hurt my neck the other
day at the dojo I was sparring yesterday
and I got and I got a hook to the side
of the Hat I'm wearing a headgear I
gotta hook to the side of that I didn't
block I didn't get the [ __ ] out of the
way so now I'm dealing with pain what is
this pain teaching me either block the
[ __ ] hit next time or get out of the
way
yeah okay so when you start to see it
coming the guy's winding up you know you
see the movement coming
when you start to see it coming and
she's behaving differently she's colder
she's withdrawn she's more distant she's
spending more time with friends sort of
things that's when you start you know
okay
what's going on here like what's really
happening because
it looks like to me and this is a
conversation you have you know like it
looks like to me like you've got one
foot out the door
yeah well what do you mean I got it you
know she'll get all defensive and [ __ ]
and that's not what's going on and maybe
that's not what's going on but maybe it
is what's going on but at least you know
you've drawn A Line in the Sand and
you've set a boundary and you're like
look
I'm not a goof I see what's happening
what's going on because if you're out
you're out like Leaf you know the door's
unlocked it's going to be locked if you
try to come back in heads up okay like
only don't play games like that right so
you'll be ready for it next time you'll
be more prepared you'll see it coming
the problem is is that see I got this
from my uh old buddy from the before the
train wreck Series right uh Sean Smith
and you know he said to me one time he
goes we create a safe world theory in
our heads right like we build this
I'm a traveling nurse I did the right
thing you know we built this life
together you know we did all these you
know we went to this city and I went to
that City because she went to and I did
all this [ __ ] and I did go invested in
the relationship and they gave her what
she wanted I went to her family events
and I traveled to where she wanted to
and I wore the [ __ ] outfit that she
wanted me to out of them I said okay and
then you start to add all this [ __ ] up
and this house of cards starts to pile
up and it gets real high okay and then
all of a sudden you know this this this
thing now becomes a safe World thing you
know in your head because you're rely on
it because it's there it doesn't move
but all it takes is like Kevin from
sales to come along and pull out that
one card and then a whole [ __ ] thing
comes crumbling down and then your
theory that led to the safe world just
ends and you're like what the [ __ ] I was
lied to
okay this entire thing that I built was
a lie and it came crumbling down so you
know what unfortunately for guys I don't
think we deal with breakups as well as
women do there's the warbright theory I
don't know if you've heard of it yeah
I've heard of it yeah okay so you know
so I don't need to repeat it yeah yeah
you know women just seem to get over
breakups a lot quicker than guys do and
women also initiate breakups a lot more
than guys do right like guys tolerate a
lot of [ __ ] women they don't you know
they're told they're beautiful
immediately You Know You're Beautiful
I'd like yeah and they have unlimited
options you know let's be honest you
know and you know like a good looking
guy doesn't have as many options as a
good looking woman okay and women are
never really single even when they're
with somebody they're always talking to
somebody so there's all these like
narratives that I you know that I sort
of drop out there and it's like it's
cool you know man like you know and Rich
I'm I'm like I'm grinding 16 hour shifts
I have a plan a goal this is a huge
[ __ ] curveball and I mean I know I
should I've been I've already like so
I've been with a couple of chicks
already trying to you know get over it
but I have I got these big goals that
I'm working on and I'm close to
attaining them and they just [ __ ]
something I don't mean it because but it
just messes up the head you know how
long how long how long
how long did you date her for what was
it a total time it's three years three
years total no respect at the end of it
just you'll be a week
you'll be shocked to know that it might
take you three years to fully forget
about her yeah legit you know like it is
what it is like if you're with a chick
for seven years you're probably gonna
think about her a lot for the first year
after then it's going to start this
little you know trickle down by about
year seven you're never even gonna think
about her ever again she'll be gone yeah
like a fart in the wind okay so that's
the reality of when you invest into a
relationship over a long-term basis
women don't invest in the same way that
you do and that's fine that's just the
way it is like I'm not saying don't deal
with women I'm not saying don't invite
them into your life but be careful about
the ones that you invite into your life
like there's certain things that you can
do to maintain the frame there's certain
things that you can do to reduce the
exposure to Kevin from sales receive
from accounting or whoever you know that
whoever it was that she got with right
yeah it's like you know did she have
social media was she posting provocative
pictures that was the problem because
she uh she had her IG she lost a little
bit of weight and she's putting uh like
her leggings on when I'm like hey like I
don't really mess with that and she knew
that I was like don't don't put up
you're beautiful I guess you're
beautiful but I only want to see you
know the internet doesn't need to see
you and she's like I'm a diamond you
need a diamond needs to be put in the
light to Sparkle some [ __ ] like that get
the [ __ ] out of here I know I know right
right there it's get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ] yeah I would have
I would have put my foot down and say
you know what you're actually going to
delete the Instagram no if that's more
important to you I said too much man I
sent way too much man but you're not
gonna do it next time no I won't
I appreciate you Richard man I
appreciate you Mike I've been listening
to you for a while man you introduced me
to a lot of people and made it a lot of
different things happen my life it's
crazy that I'm talking to you I really
appreciate you man do me a solid if you
got value out of the call if you got
value out of my book go to Amazon and
tell us you already did they want to go
you're the man appreciate you brother
thanks Mike take care hey guys I really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out